[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to another
episode of
overrated underrated with me garyvee
[Music]
drock let's just get right into the show
i am ready
gamestop's stock is properly rated
um because there's you know there's the
earnings of it and like the reality of
the business
and there's obviously the community uh
the wall street the reddit
the discords the thing of that nature
the market is the market
thus it's properly rated make the
stallion
meg the stallion i'm gonna go with
properly rated as well
i always love artists in this moment
they've had a heat heat
and right now that's in you know you can
only have so much heat heat
britney spears in sync the baby make the
stallion you can only have so much
heat heat and then you go into this
place which i call is the properly
rated spot what happens next is what
leads to
overrated or underrated that follow-up
that consistency
that next we'll see properly rated
godzilla from king kong the movie
godzilla versus king kong the movie
is overrated i did that because i'm not
sure
but some of you sci-fi like nerd life
nerd like
nerd life just lost your [ __ ] and i want
to see your comments
converse smash bros super smash bros is
underrated
that game is [ __ ] amazing me aj
brandon warnicky um randy morton
brandon's brother
uh had some real epic battles through
the years
i like that game a lot
weighted blankets i've done it a little
bit
um
properly rated i'm in a properly rated
mood usually i'm very
very tight on that i think they're
properly rated i don't have a whole lot
of opinions
on weighted blankets dirty coin
doge underrated i own none
you know there's so much good [ __ ] going
on nfts doge
bitcoin sports cards you know there's so
much
you can't do everything you know i love
just communities and technology and
changes
i mean i remember douche was six [ __ ]
years ago or five years ago
i might even have some doge in a wallet
that i've lost
i'm one of those individuals in crypto
that i was dabbling
that like log in i don't even know the
existence of some of my
i'm thrilled i found my bitcoin i was
playing it loose it was [ __ ] like
crazy back then now it's like
not crazy and it's fun to watch so the
doge mafia gets a little love today
underrated
ice hockey the nintendo game that nobody
in the world can beat me in or the
macro game of hockey
ice hockey is a nintendo game that
nobody on earth can beat me in for a
nintendo entertainment system
you mean ice like hockey underrated one
of the best sports to watch
play is i don't even consider it a big
four sport anymore i think ufc
slash overall mma and soccer
football in the us have trump and east i
mean
i literally look at ice hockey behind
ufc mma soccer
football we're talking u.s now and
esports
i look at ice hockey hockey as literally
the
seventh sport where it used to be the
fourth
i think they've done a really poor job
in marketing and branding
because the game going a hockey game is
[ __ ] epic
it's one of the best if not the best
actual sports experiences
wendy's twitter account wendy's twitter
account is underrated it's extremely
well done
it's one of the few brands last four
years that has done thoughtful witty
impactful the fact that you're asking me
about wendy's twitter account is the
meta
of why it's underrated ant-man ant-man
like the comic book action hero paul
rudd
yeah overrated like
the fact that people even know ant-man
because of the movie like ant-man's
[ __ ] garbage
board salesforce the company underrated
extremely well executed
company in the last 20 years really
progressive thoughtful
mark benioff ceo very quick to move in
m a using its advantage of finances
to gobble up market share for full
integration salesforce underrated ariana
grande
ariana grande underrated incredibly
iconic voice true pop star
get underrated because i think people
make judgment on personal life or
longevity
or just of the moment she's sustained
back to magnus stallion
i i'm looking forward to sitting here in
five years saying that
magnus stallion is underrated because
she's been able to do what ariana grande
has done
has done for the last five years ariana
grande is underrated lonzo ball
lonzo ball is very early right now
oh lonzo not lamelo i'm sorry lonzo ball
has a player underrated
and i think lamelo's heat
has him a little bit refocused because i
like the way he's playing i love that
competitive chip
i think a lot these guys are young i
think lonzo is a player
underrated that was not a sports card
reference because most modern stuff is
overrated kawhi leonard kawhi leonard in
my opinion
is properly rated i don't think he's
underrated
i don't think he's overrated i'm going
to go with properly rated last year's
playoff run
wasn't great toronto's team the year
after
and played so well that it yeah i think
i think a wise i think hawaii's properly
rated
and it's like gun gun gun to my head
it's like
0.0001 slightly overrated 0.00
so he's properly rated but just to give
you my vibes on where his game is at
this point in his career
work-life balance work-life balance is
underrated
who gets to decide and show the split
screen now team like
move me over like what is work life
balance it's a politically correct
conversation in today's environment that
uses outside forces to try to impose
their will
on humans so that they dwell on
something that that actually doesn't
mean anything
people are way too judgmental and over
analyzing work-life balance in today's
modern pr society
and so if you feel good about it then
you'll win like i have no interest
in making you happy about my work-life
balance you worry about your work-life
balance
a couple posts ago who gets to decide
your work-life balance is overrated
you know like [ __ ] you you don't get to
decide my work-life balance
and i don't get to decide yours like who
gets what are you the god
of work-life balance work-life balance
is
underrated because balance is underrated
finding balance and being happy content
underrated people's judgment of each
other
on work-life balance grossly and i mean
[ __ ] grossly overrated
nothing nasa for me
overrated for many people in the
comments underrated what an
impact on our society it's had
for me the angle i'm taking is i've
always genuinely
not been interested in science didn't
give a [ __ ] about
[ __ ] about going to space or not so for
me
overrated it's impact i mean i i had a
test on me recently for my health
because i'm getting really trying to
live forever [ __ ] and like
they're like this was originally figured
out by nasa 20 years ago and now we
figured out how to use this for heart
health
i'm like [ __ ] nasa it's like i have
crazy respect but for me
overrated because i just don't like
going to the moon and science in general
even though it is
important so putting people on mars
that's the question underrated because
it's
cool like i don't think i'm gonna get to
see it
or actually actually do actually let me
take that back i actually do think i'll
get to see it i won't be doing it
does it still take five years to get
there yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
i probably do it by the way if i was
much younger like
it's cool underrated one already
one direction is properly rated because
they're now at the life cycle back to
the whole bag in ariana grande
one direction's now just at that place
that they've been out of it for so long
that the recall is like 24 to 60 months
away
the comeback then let's get together and
do it [ __ ] which is gonna get everybody
who's
what is one direction here every 27 year
old right now who's gonna be 36 at the
time
or 31 or every 30 year old who's going
to be 36 at the time or 34 is going to
be like
so right now properly rated soon to be
underrated
than to be back on the scene underrated
tony hawk sits in a place
similar to babe
ruth sits in a place similar to
joe lewis sits in a place similar to
jim thorpe and i know some like jim i
know joe lewis and jim thorpe's not
going to land for a lot of you
but like is the guy
guy pioneer like run dmc
like todd miss edison
like benjamin franklin like he's the guy
like
like the face of the birth
of a pop culture platform known as
skateboarding
oh gee like the guy guy baby showers
baby showers are underrated baby showers
are underrated because it is a
marketing manipulation of society
to make people think they need to do it
just to sell more stuff
that is brilliant literally was invented
like there was no baby showers 100 years
ago it was invented
by marketers companies a human the
culture
that has now become a commerce event and
a part of like the way you
think it is people just think it is kind
of like diamond rings for engagement
people just think it is well guess what
no no a company decided that
pretty amazing [ __ ] baby showers grossly
underrated
for the brilliance and execution of
something
now is accepted california
california
i think california is properly rated
[Music]
why or you go next one
california is a really fun enigma i
think of so many things wine country
the la scene they do great in work-life
balance
yoga lifestyle weather like just
agriculture socially so progressive like
so many interesting things
and so many counters that same thing
like i make fun of a lot of my la
friends
at a deep love properly rated pineapple
pizza
topping uncomfortably overrated
pineapple hawaiian pizza or whatever
pineapple on pizza is [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that this the whole sweet like
strawberries and salad pineapple and
pizza
i don't [ __ ] with that sweet i like them
individually i [ __ ] with pizza
i know i said it was a delivery pete
like people got crazy about the pizza
last
episode i [ __ ] with pizza though and
pineapples i [ __ ] with pineapples
together not as much grossly overrated
what is that naruto i don't know what no
but tell me what it is
very popular
uh bird scooter burnt scooters
yeah underrated for the innovation
grossly over valued at one point
of its cycle haven't stayed close to it
long enough
i'm gonna go with properly rated i think
they got caught up in that
world where companies just got valued at
a billion fast
but they might have executed since i
just i'm so undereducated on where that
sits these days
um underrated on the idea because that
was a real good hack to the
uber lyft ecosystem at one time i was
paying attention just felt like
super overvalued and money off the table
which de-incentivizes from a vc
vulnerability founder thing
but so i'm just gonna go properly rated
because i don't have enough data to make
a great call
left or right that is the show
we have a question of the day we have a
question of the day
for you you have a question for me okay
what is the dumbest way that you injure
yourself
what is the dumbest way that i've
injured myself
we're thinking about a story time like
adding that parallel element to that
what is the dumbest way i've injured
myself so i've never broken
a bone in my body i've only
um oh i got a great one
i have a chipped tooth because
i was making pretend in 1986
that i was george the animal steel who
was a wrestler who used to bite the
turnbuckle
and i put my mouth in the hood slot
of a car and was making pretend and then
some jerked and my tooth chipped
i chipped the same tooth
a second time because six months my mom
was beside herself
six months later i swung a baseball bat
and was like we were playing one-on-one
and i kind of like
turned at the same time and the bat to
go get the ball because i missed
and the bat hit me in the mouth and i
reshipped it differently
that was done we will see you next time
on overrated under i like the story time
at the end just a little more
story time might just be a good show
period you know because i wanna
team actually let's add this by the way
admin team like team gary don't edit
anything i know you tighten it up i want
this one to go straight
the thing i didn't know all of it
straight
the overrated underrated is to inspire
you to find ways to produce content
what the reason i'm just making one last
point you can put this in black and
white ps at the end or something
story time is just a good way to help
you like i they wanted to add this as a
format at the end
i'm not sure it's not just a new pillar
of content where you just ask three
questions like story time and story time
[ __ ] story time people are like what
do i do for content story time
i wasn't thinking about chipping my
tooth i've never told you that no daily
be no weekly be nothing
there it is [ __ ] story time we'll see
you next time on overrated
underrated youtube watcher what's up
it's garyvee first of all thank you so
much i hope you're doing super well
during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you